what is the emotion manufacturing and
distribution
industry what is that uh that's uh the
entertainment business that's what uh
that's what we're doing that's uh we're
not chasing Trends we're not making
Trends we're not doing all those things
that uh Executives and critics and
people would like us to think we're
doing uh we are trying to make people
feel something whether it's movies
television anything that's the goal
you're not educating people you may do
those things in addition to moving
people but your job as a screenwriter
and the screenwriters are the first
filmmakers your job is to make people
feel something so you're in the emotion
manufacturing business and just and the
distribution of that emotion that's what
we do that's our
job so when people think of uh Hollywood
uh we think of Glamour and and action
but really it's almost about it's like a
puppet we're having our strings pulled
absolutely I mean that's the contract
the contract we make with the audience
is they pay us money in the form of a
box office ticket or in the form of a
paying their cable bill or their
streaming app Bill and in return we make
them feel something that's our contract
with them they don't even necessarily
know it if you ask them they probably
wouldn't necessarily describe it the
audience that way but it is that it
could be laughter it could be tears it
could be being scared it could be having
your pulse ING with excitement it could
be getting turned on but it's something
that makes them feel something that's
the relationship uh between the
filmmaker the screenwriter and the
audience what's the difference between
expressing emotion and evoking
emotion uh the difference between
expressing and evoking emotion is
radically uh different and Incredibly
important to for the screenwriter to
identify any kind of writer um
we've all been you know told and we have
a in society now there's sort of a a
sense of we're all supposed to be
expressing ourselves and that's great
it's a wonderful thing to do but I don't
want to see your therapy session and you
don't want to see mine and I certainly
don't want to pay to see your therapy
session so um our job is not to just
express ourselves if you just want to um
if you if you write down your innermost
thoughts and feelings on a piece of
paper that's therapy but if you do it in
such a away so that someone else can
read it and feel what you feel that's
art and that's what we're supposed to be
doing that part of the process gets
forgotten a lot especially now when it
seems like just expressing emotion
should be enough no it's not if the
audience didn't feel it it doesn't
matter the audience is the completion of
The Arc in any art form but especially a
popular art form like movies uh until an
audience feels it and responds to it you
haven't completed your task uh and they
will leave the theater frustrated if
they haven't had that uh that experience
uh our job is to make them feel
something not for us to express what we
feel in order to make them feel
something yes very often you do have to
tap into something that uh you feel
deeply and get it on the screen when I
write television I'm doing the same
thing I just not necessarily uh I may be
using someone else's characters or
someone else's scenario but I have to
find something in that story that that I
can uh feel strongly about and then try
to get that on the screen but my job is
to communicate it to the audience not
just to feel it not just to express it
is that why uh people often say don't do
narration o like an opening with a
narration or that's totally different um
I don't there is there is some
relationship uh in the sense of uh any
kind of VoiceOver narration
instinctively distances the audience
audience from the story you're telling
but sometimes that's good um some of the
greatest movies ever made have voiceover
narration as a part of them because it
it does distance the audience and tells
the audience they're about to see
something that's perhaps more important
than they would have realized I'm
thinking about the opening of network
for example which has a a an omniscient
narrator uh at the beginning at the end
and occasionally throughout the story
and it works very effectively because uh
we it's a satire and it was important
that we occasionally step back and hear
in essence the voice of God telling us
something important is happening here
but if it's a crutch if if it's used as
a crutch to just explain stuff that the
uh screenwriters and the directors
weren't good enough to get on camera
then it usually is something to be
avoided but almost every Billy Wilder
movie has voiceover of some sort it's
it's a it's a very useful tool and it
can be very effective so I don't know
that it's that directly uh related why
do you encourage writers to feel it
write it and then analyze
it
um it's among the most crucial parts of
my te teaching technique and my
philosophy of
screenwriting most screenwriting books
uh and teachers are teaching you
backwards they're teaching you to
analyze all these successful films they
all have these things in common now if
you go back and plug in you do the exact
same formula and just plug in your
characters you'll have a success too and
it absolutely does not work that way
because of what I because of um because
the film is uh its purpose is to make
the audience feel something it's
important that you start with your right
brain I'm being very simplistic now
psychologically but the right brain is
roughly responsible for the emotional
intelligence of of our of our
personalities the left brain is the
rational part they're telling you to
start with the left brain which is say
analyze it then write it and maybe
you'll feel it in there somewhere that's
incorrect in my opinion that you need to
start with by feeling it feeling the
passion of it try to get that onto the
page and then after you have then go
back and analyze it and of course that
last step of analyzing it is critical to
make sure that the audience is going to
get what you intended it isn't just
first blurt you're not just putting
something on the page you then you then
analyze it uh and reanalyze it and re
reanalyze it to make sure it's doing
what you want to do but first you have
to feel it um it's uh it's what I call
organic screenwriting as opposed to uh
the more formulaic screenwriting uh
theories which most screenwriting uh
books and teachers uh tend to uh tend to
to promote um that's there a difference
between something that's well structured
and just something that's written to a
formula I do a lot of screenwriting
Consulting have for years with some
success a lot of my uh clients have gone
on and had their films made and uh
that's often what I find myself doing is
trying to strip away all that uh
analysis that they've been taught that
by by page so and so I have to be here
but page so and so I have to be here
strip that away get back to what what is
your what you passionate about what did
you why did you write this story to
begin with what are you excited about
and
then uh get that on the page or get that
at least the process started and then go
back and analyze and see is there a
better way we could do it should that be
moved from here to there and all the
other uh decisions that go into properly
structuring a screenplay but if you
don't feel it first you're pretty much
doomed and so how can we reconcile in
ourselves the the the right brain but
not letting us kind of become unhinged
you know where we're kind of we've got a
bottle of whatever and we're just going
to pour it all out but then we find out
it's a big jumbled mess yeah somebody
once said and I thought it was a smart
thing the rules of screenwriting are for
when the script doesn't work so that you
know if if you go I mean you shouldn't
have to give it to someone for them to
tell you this is completely meaningless
to me I don't get it at all uh it's
really our job to having written to go
back and then start shaping it in a more
refined way and as one gets more
practice at it uh you instinctively
start to avoid some of the potholes and
you sense oh this is going on too long
or whatever but but first it's important
to get it down um it's also a test uh
for younger writers who uh are used to
writing in in in a medium on a device
that allows them to just blurt
everything out and it looks like a a
script it's in final draft it looks like
a script so that must be good well it's
not good uh you have to force yourself
to go back and rewrite and rewrite
rewrite and rewrite and refine it put it
away take pick it up look at it again uh
this is all presupposing of course that
that the before you start writing
dialogue and scenes first it has to be
properly structured so that first most
of the projects that whether it's in
movies or television most of our time is
spent in structuring the story properly
not just learning out dialogue the
dialogue is the easy part um so once
it's properly structured then you're
usually not going to go too far a field
but but even that that that that theory
of writing from Passion applies to the
structuring of the story as well you
want to you want to picture in your head
and and get the things structured in a
way that is that in which the passion of
your idea first and foremost comes
through that's the that's the most
important thing without that you're just
writing another screenplay that will
disappear with all the thousands and
thousands of other mediocre
screenplays